he is the quarterback of the dallas
cowboys getting set for monday night
football against the philadelphia eagles
he is none other than dak prescott how
are you dak prescott i'm doing well rich
thank you for having me i appreciate you
being had man that's for darn short and
i appreciate the calling so um how are
you feeling how's it going i'm feeling
yeah i'm feeling great healthy uh ready
to go ready to get out there and uh have
a great week three home opener i'm just
excited for this atmosphere what was the
most difficult part of your rehab to get
ready for this season
i mean honestly i'd say just the
beginning um the first couple of months
when i was in a cast and on crutches or
on the scooter and i couldn't
really do anything uh be i couldn't be
mobile i couldn't do a lot of rehab and
things that
um i felt like i was
accomplishing uh so that was the
toughest part but the moment that i was
able to to start seeing progress and
start um knocking one thing off started
getting
movement in my foot and walking again
um from there it was just uh it was fun
it was a challenging process that i
embraced and uh every not
a day didn't go by that it wasn't hard
but i embraced it all and had fun with
the process and just now to be back and
look back a month ago it's crazy but i'm
thankful for it no doubt crazy for sure
but when when did you finally get some
traction on that comeback i'm just
trying to figure it out
how long it was what point of the season
was it for for the cowboys um without
you when when did you finally begin to
start feeling that you were gaining
traction towards positivity
oh well i mean the first few months i
mean what happened in october um
basically had another one in december
and so it wasn't until late january
mid-january that i was able to to start
walking again and start doing the small
things that were that was going to be
the beginning of the of the comeback and
to start the physical rehab part more
than just um
allowing the treatment and the stems and
all that thing but actually
being mobile and making making a step
was
probably right before february so
literally you made a step
when you're saying like um in terms of
progress not an actual step right in
january or february or was it an actual
step it was an actual actual step
probably then wow in in early january
wow i mean because so many fans dak
think that
you know you're a young guy um you know
you've got top of the
top of the uh food chain medical care
of course you're gonna come back and
it's just kind of a no-brainer and now
we're seeing you in the first two weeks
look no worse than where and it's just
i'll be honest with you i'm watching i'm
not even thinking about it i'm not
thinking about it do you
no i don't at all but i mean i give
credit to
the support i have around me i give
credit to brit brown in the training
room uh jim maurer greg gaither hanson
yang
all of those guys that uh played a part
in my rehab and played a part in pushing
me and pushing each and every day to to
be better than i was before um and not
only just rehabbing the ankle but
finding other ways to get better in
every aspect of the game um and it just
really showing i don't think about it
when i'm out there and i feel like a
better player than i was before i left
the game how so
how i mean in every aspect i mean i feel
healthy in my lower body but i'm working
with my quarterback coach john beck
and luke miller my upper body feels
better than it did
i've probably lost weight and in better
shape than i've ever been
and experienced i mean just five years
in the nfl going into year six um it's
all just starting to click and i see
things faster uh moving faster mentally
and i think all of that plays a part in
just being the best player that i've
been up to this point zak prescott here
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
getting ready for monday night football
against the philadelphia eagles
um and then and the opener against tampa
uh did you did you need to take a hit
did you
um did you just after one throw just get
out there go okay let's go i mean was it
anything like that for you yeah i mean
before before i took the field i had
nerves and i was wondering well these
nerves go away but
um three games into it and thinking
about five years i've always had nerves
so that was no different than any game
but after that first throw
um that first play i mean went in there
made a check made that first throw
everything went away and it was it was
back to normal and it was a great
feeling and just uh i didn't need to
take a hit but i think later in the game
when i took a hit and especially when i
made a run and made a cut uh is when i
felt i just felt thankful at that point
like yeah i don't even think about this
i'm moving i'm making cuts and as i said
i felt better than i ever have and also
i've i've you know been around this a
long time dak you know uh i've seen
athletes who get paid or in your case
piz aid and it's it's a pressure that um
that they're constantly trying to live
up to it i wonder what you think about
that idea
yeah i mean i've never played this game
for money um i've never wanted to make
it to the nfl for the money was always
about playing the game i love and doing
it at the highest level against the best
men there are in the world so
um that's that's continued to be my
inspiration motivation every day when i
wake up is being the best of the best
and it has nothing to do with what the
paycheck is or what this position um
gets paid uh so i mean i think that's
that's obviously great and it's
obviously a blessing and it's a
generational blessing but um that has
plays no factor in my mind or any factor
in what i wake up and do that said um
avoiding somebody like aaron donald or
negotiating with jerry jones which one
is tougher
i'd say
i'd say worrying about aaron donald i
mean i have great people that i trust
and obviously i trusted the jones and
the cowboys organization and getting it
getting the deal done so um i didn't put
a lot of energy and focus into that um
and as i said i just believe and had
faith that i'd be here and trusted
trusted my team and trusted them and um
obviously they got me a great great deal
they sure did dak i i you know when i
interviewed you at the super bowl before
the 2020 season uh
after the 2019 season and i talked to
you and i told you the story demarcus
ware once told me that jerry jones when
he really is getting ready to sign on
the dotted line he calls you into his
office with no agents lights some votive
candles you know and and and just stares
at you and asks you if you want to be a
dallas cowboy did that ever
happen to you dak did that
moment happen maybe not exactly that
scenario but we had a few office visits
um and they were always great but um
they were they're just really
communicating
um at that point what both sides were
moving towards and what both sides
wanted um but at the end of the day
um stephen and jerry hashed it out with
my agent todd france and that was all on
them and i give them credit um i just
got a call from todd and then later
about a couple hours later i was in in
the jones office hugging and um knowing
that i had a future that is were there
no candles then is what you're saying no
vote of pandas there wasn't candles but
there's lots of smiles
i like it dak prescott here on the rich
eisen show the challenge the
philadelphia eagles represent on monday
night football is what
i mean as a division opponent um you
know take the records away take
everything away anytime that you play a
division opponent but especially uh
starting off the season home opener for
us um it's going to be exciting monday
night football um we know that they're
got a new coaching staff so i'd say that
the biggest challenge is um
the uh the unexpected not knowing if who
they are is what they've done these
first two weeks or if they're planning
on throwing something out different for
us because we're a division team um but
just going in there and sticking true to
our rules into what we we know best as
an offense but i think it's important
that we capture the momentum we capture
it early feed off the home crowd and
monday night football and start this
division vision off the right way with
the win well what is what the offense
does best deck is it putting the uh the
bonus on you 45 times to throw or the
balance because
we've seen both this year already it's
just the ability to be able to do either
one be able to to
really dial in whether it's the past
game because that's what's needed or as
you saw last week lean on the offensive
line in the run game because that's
where we're making the hay so um when
you have the talent that we have when
you have the chemistry the core the
brotherhood that we have on this offense
you just you just go out there with the
plan to be balanced but if one needs to
take over the other um we're willing to
do that as well and how as a fact that
you've already gone toe to toe with the
world champs and spent
uh a full day in the building where the
super bowl's going to take place
kind of give you uh the knowledge that
you have the ability to make a run
to that stadium you just won in this
past week and lift the trophy whatever i
mean i start when you go back to the
spring with the way that we came in and
expectations that we put on ourselves as
a team
the expectations and standards we're
going to hold ourselves as an offense
and the defense and special teams um
we've had a great we had a great
offseason they carried into training
camp and then um obviously starting the
season off um as you said going
toe-to-toe with the team that just won
it out out there at their place and then
going on the road and beating a good
team a good young team that's got a
powerful offense that the defense
allowed us to make some plays
we're creating momentum and we're
creating momentum we're going to need it
as we start off at home and use this uh
use it as a division um against a
division opponent so i think it's
important i think it's all momentum that
we can take and continue to carry but
build off of uh to get where we want to
be how jacked are you seriously like uh
that that that this is happening to you
in your life i mean what if i told you
you know what's the snap cut to eight
years ago what's going on right now in
2021 for you what would you said
uh very humbly um i probably would have
would have believed you just on the fact
of the expectations and the way and the
standard that i hold myself to and um
just everything that's happening in my
life uh i want it to happen um and i
wake up every day trying to hold myself
accountable to be the best player and
the best person and the best i can be in
whatever role is required and i've been
that way for for a long time and i've
only grown and everything that's
happened in my life has allowed me to
grow more and i'm just thankful thankful
to be where i'm at thankful to be a
great organization with great teammates
great coaches and great people around me
that continue to push me and i just know
everything's going to continue to go up
and what would it mean for you to grab
that lombardi trophy hold it up and hand
it to jerry jones yeah it'd mean
everything i played this game because i
want to be a winner i want to be a
champion and as i said i've always
dreamed about being an nfl to play with
the best of the best but to be the best
amongst them and that's what that
lombardi trophy does and i think it's
important for i'm not only just the one
i want to get i want to get there but
for the cowboy fans and for this
organization um i think they deserve to
be back there and that'd mean everything
yeah jerry told us last year that uh af
before the super bowl where they won
their third he told the he said he's
prayed to the lord and said if you give
me this one i won't come asking again
but he's ready to redo that deal is what
he said
[Music]
uh yeah i can see that we're going to go
get we're going to try everything that
we can do and be our best each day to go
get him this uh to go get him another
one jack thanks for the call appreciate
it good luck on monday night football
against the philadelphia eagles let's
chat again soon for sure rich thank you
thank you always great yeah right back
at you the one and only dak prescott of
the dallas cowboys right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here